Hello, I'm Soldier Boy.
The world knows who I am.
What do I have to say it? I'm Soldier Boy.
Did you know drugs and drug related crime
have become
a nationwide problem all across America?
Drugs are destroying people's lives.
But you don't have to be a superhero
to fight back
because your superpower power
is just saying no.
So when someone offers you drugs,
you tell them.
Soldier Boy said taking drugs is not cool.
And anyone who does is a loser.
Remember,
real heroes don't use drugs.
But the cool thing to do is just say no.
I sound like a jackass.
Who approved this script? Stan Edgar.
Get him on the phone.
I'm not saying this
Finally.
This is hot
iced unprofessional.
Let's go to the top.
If taking drugs is uncool,
I'm the most uncool
on the planet.
you. Actually, we're going to need to go
one more time.
No, we're not.
Really?
Just need one more take.
No, that's a wrap.
Okay, great.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
They dropped a brand new boys
Gen V promo with Jensen Ackles Soldier Boy
coming back.
He will be part of the Gen V
episodes. I'll explain what's going on.
Obviously a lot of jokes here about him
doing pieces like they force
Captain America
to do in the Marvel Universe.
Soldier Boy
is part of a larger group
of like the main superheroes from the boys
that are going to show up on Gen V,
That'll help set up
what's happening
during the boys season 4.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
They're actually dropping
the first three episodes next week
I'll do a video for them
after I finish my Ahsoka video.
But then after that, all the boys Gen V
episodes will be weekly.
There'll be eight episodes total,
just like the main series.
It'll be interesting
to see which of the seven characters,
the other major boy's characters
show up in each episode,
because it does sound like most of them
will be in the Gen V episodes.
the main thing here with them
bringing Jensen Ackles Soldier Boy back
is that he ended season three being
put back into crowd stations by Mallory
because in the universe of the boys,
some of the most powerful characters
like Homelander Soldier Boy
on the TV show, at least like Stormfront,
nobody has been able to kill them.
There are a couple of exceptions of that.
Like Stormfront was able to kill herself.
But like Stormfront during season
two at the beginning of season three
at least was a good example.
They were able to hurt her so badly
at the end of season two
that she went full panic and Skywalker
on Mustafar with no arms and legs,
pretty much turned
into a human charcoal briquette.
but they still weren't
able to actually kill her.
She was the only one
who was powerful enough to kill herself.
Homelander probably could have done it to
So if she was that hard
to kill, Homelander even more powerful
would be even harder to kill. Now.
Yes, he can be killed, theoretically,
but there's only one person
on the planet who's able to do that
in the comics and on the TV show.
They'll probably use the Ryan Twist
for that,
those who say that
because Ryan is his biological son,
he got all of his powers,
he is powerful enough to kill Homelander.
Now, in
the comics, things were very different.
The original version of Black
the War was a genetic clone of Homelander
that Vought created to keep Homelander in
check is a sort of failsafe.
It was their way of creating
a deterrent capable of having any effect
on Homelander
if he ever went off the rails
and lost control of them
So that's why in the comic
book, black noir is always standing around
where Homelander is like
he's always keeping an eye on him
just in case he goes off the rails
in all the terrible stuff
that Homelander is accused of doing.
Like really, really terrible stuff
is actually done by Black noir
who dresses up in Homelander's costume
occasionally
because the comic book Genetic Clone of
Homelander has already gone insane.
things went off the rails
in the comic book
way, way faster than the on the TV show.
on the TV show.
Though their version of black noir
is like a completely different character.
He's not meant to be
a genetic clone of homelander.
They've kind of given that role
to Ryan as his biological son.
If you haven't read the original Boys
comic book, though, you can read all about
that other version of Black where it is
crazy, in the original version.
Homelander did father a child
with butcher's wife, Becca.
But early in the story,
like before the events
of the actual comic book pick up Butcher
killed it right after it was born
that was meant to be the beginning of him
creating the boys team going
after Homelander the other superheroes.
so it was way, way more hardcore
than the backstory that they went
with on the TV show.
If they toned it down big time, even
though it does still seem pretty nuts.
the other big change
that the TV show made,
though, was making Soldier Boy
Homelander's genetic father.
They also made the TV shows
Soldier Boy way
more powerful than the comic book versions
there were two versions in the comics.
Jensen Ackles version was kind of
like a combination of both of them,
but the original version was meant to be
the direct parody of Captain America's
origin story,
Getting the super Soldier serum Soldier
Boy was created by the United States
as their first compound v superhero
to counter the Nazis
creating their own compound.
These superhero Stormfront
So it's kind of like Red Skull
in Captain America in the Marvel movies
There are a couple of Easter eggs
for this on the TV show,
but in the comics, Soldier
Boy was meant to be a terrible superhero.
He didn't know how to use his powers.
He wound up getting his whole squad killed
in comic book.
Malory was part of his squad in World
War Two.
They moved the timeline up on the TV
show version, and it was Vietnam for her.
but Jensen Ackles version.
The character did come from World War Two.
the other big change was some twist behind
the iron cash version of Stormfront.
but basically the same vibe
as the comic book version.
The character
she was the first Compound V superhero.
Vought was a Nazi scientist
during World War Two.
She was his wife and created a compound V
two tested on her successfully.
then he was brought to the United States
through Operation Paperclip and created
Vought American, which is the company
that Stan Edgar was running up to.
The events of season three.
the original comic book.
Mallory killed that first soldier boy
as revenge for getting their squad killed.
but on the show
they said that Jensen Ackles
version of the character just continue
living through all the subsequent wars
and Vought kept
using him trying to make money off of him
because he was functionally immortal,
like a couple of the other superheroes
like Homelander, like Stormfront to
that was one of the things they didn't
really get into during the boys.
These three kind of a missed opportunity
like what was the relationship back
in the early days between Soldier
Boy and Stormfront, especially after
she came to the United States, is sort of
going by a different superhero names.
they would have had
to have known each other,
but the whole idea
is that the Jensen Ackles version
just continued serving for Vought.
They're trying to make money off of him
until Stan Edgar came along
and came up with the idea
to create Homelander
a much more refined version
of the compound formula given
to basically the genetic material
taken from their most powerful superhero.
The day which was Soldier Boy,
Basically it was stand Edgar
trying to create Superman.
the whole idea
that when they created Homelander though,
they infused his fetus with way
more compound V that they would normally
give to like a baby or young child.
so was like someone who is already
very powerful, giving way
way more compound than anybody
normally would be given in.
On top of that
it was a refined version of the formula
that's the main reason
why people like Queen Mave
who are also like super powerful
she's
one of the most powerful superheroes.
Next to Homelander
isn't nearly as powerful as Homelander
because he was given way less compound B
But even though soldier boy is not as
powerful as Homelander or even Stormfront,
he's still virtually unkillable by anyone
but someone like Homelander.
The only reason why he didn't kill him
at the end of season
three was that lingering feelings
he had from his father
seemed like he was about to kill them
for a hot second there.
But his whole thing was that
he craved real family, which he never had.
He was raised like a test rat,
basically in isolation,
which is why he wound up
being so messed up in the head
because they basically locked him
in a room his entire life.
that's
how he developed that alternate persona
that he was talking to in the mirror,
who might actually be responsible
for a lot of the really crazy stuff
that he does,
even though technically
it's like he's still doing it all,
but it is an ultra persona inside him.
Does manifesting when he does that, is
almost like a moon night situation
with the alternate personas
like dissociative identity disorder.
The difference, though,
is that moon night in the Marvel Universe
usually isn't aware
when he switches to another persona
or when another one takes over.
the only reason why the different versions
were able to talk to each other
was because they were in the afterlife.
So the fact that it seems like
Homelander is aware of his other persona
seems like a completely different thing
that was going on with New Night,
They haven't said exactly
what Soldier Boy is going to be doing
during the boys GMB episodes,
but my assumption, because he's probably
supposed to be in crayon in present day,
is that
they'll have archival footage of him
doing weird or funny stuff or those funny
pieces, the how to videos, kind of like
Captain America did in Spider-Man
Homecoming.
one of their major new characters
from the comics
that they're introducing on
GMB will be Tech Night.
I've already done
a couple of videos about him,
so I'll link those at the end of this
and down to the description below.
he used to be part of the payback team
with Stormfront before Stormfront became
part of the boys
in Originally Tech Night was supposed
to become a member of the boys,
but that spot was given to Starlight
in the events of season one.
that was meant to be a result of all the
weird mental problems that Tech night had.
He can't stop
trying to have sex with stuff
it winds up turning into a big plot point.
Maybe we'll see a version of that in
like the boys season four at some point.
the whole idea though is that Tech
Night is meant to be
a combination parody of Batman
in Iron Man and DC and Marvel.
But on the TV show, the showrunner said
that they go more in a Batman direction
just because he felt like
it was more ripe for parody.
That's why in the trailer
it seems like he's a good dork
in university
in his Bruce Wayne type of persona
when they announced that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan
was actually going to be in the boys
season four,
like this is a behind the scenes picture
then filming the boys season four,
it seems like
he's going to be a government
agent working with Butcher or something
like that, originally.
I hope that
he'd be their version of Tech Night
and they use it to do
some more jokes about his Batman v
Superman character, Thomas Wayne,
because we almost got a version
of Flashpoint Batman
in The Flash movie, too,
and it was going to be
his version of the character.
there were like ten different versions
of The Flash movie
with like a whole bunch
of different directors
across a bunch of different years,
then trying to get that movie made.
And obviously the version we saw did
not have a version of Thomas Wayne Batman.
but originally
he was the flash point Batman
so which would have made a lot more sense
if he would actually been
in the movie instead.
so when they announced
that they were doing
the Tech Knight character,
everyone was like, Oh my God, it's
got to be Jeffrey Dean Morgan.
It would be so perfect.
Doesn't hurt that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan does So many messed up characters
like Negan on The Walking Dead series.
they didn't say when the Boys Season four
is going to release.
My assumption is it'll be sometime like
late spring or early summer next year,
maybe even around this time,
just depending on what happens
with everything being delayed,
the hottie with the Gen
Z episode setting up the boys season
four is that it's basically like
a version of X-Men in Xavier's University.
like Clancy.
Brown is kind of
like an evil version of Professor X.
There is a version of X-Men in the Boys
comics.
They're called the G-men.
So that's why I say that
good-Looking University is kind of like
their version of the G-men, basically,
they originally pitched
the show is sort of like
a combination of Hunger Games
meets the X-Men in the Marvel Universe
all the kids are competing to win
a spot on the seven.
So what might wind up happening
is that someone does wind up
winning at the end of the season
and we see them on the boys
during season four,
but they also use the season to set up
larger plot lines that are going on
in the background too.
especially because Victoria Neuman
is going to be on the B episodes
and there's this whole plot of Vought
trying to take over the White House,
basically.
And she's basically the path
for them to do that.
whatever Easter eggs or teasers,
we wind up seeing an episode,
of course, on the clue.
Those are my videos, so no worries.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channels.
You don't miss any of those
if you have any special requests
or questions
about what's going on with the boys stuff,
just write them below in the comments.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Ahsoka Episode 7
video We'll post next week.
After they release it, click here
for my Episode 7 trailer and click
here for that brand new Cal Kestis Easter
Egg during the recent Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!